anticipación y alivio en
kiev
estos 16 niños están de vuelta en
Ucrania después de pasar al menos cuatro
meses en campamentos de vacaciones en la
crimea ocupada y Rusia
la ong ayuda a los padres a viajar a
Rusia para recoger a sus hijos
es muy emotivo no podemos expresar
nuestros sentimientos con palabras
el viaje duró 13 días les impidieron
salir de Rusia en dos pasos fronterizos
distintos antes de llegar sanos y salvos
a Casa Don
al día siguiente
tomó declaración a los niños
trabajamos con el fiscal y la Corte
Penal Internacional Así que vamos a
enviar todos estos testimonios a la cpu
estas familias son originarias de la
región de jerson los padres entregaron a
sus hijos a las fuerzas rusas durante la
ocupación tras la promesa de mantenerlos
fuera de peligro Durante los combates
pero mucho más tarde les dijeron que
tendrían que ir ellos mismos a Rusia
para traer de vuelta a sus hijos
al principio empezaron a retrasar las
vacaciones escolares después gersón
sufrió un duro ataque luego cortaron la
electricidad el agua y la calefacción
cuando se retiraron de gersón las
fuerzas rusas se llevaron consigo a
todos los civiles que pudieron una vez
se han ido es extremadamente difícil
Localizar a los niños y mucho más
traerlos de vuelta a casa primero
tenemos que encontrar a los padres que
buscan a sus hijos luego tenemos que
encontrar a los niños no sabemos A dónde
los envían porque los rusos ocultan esa
información
la mayoría de estos niños dicen que no
fueron maltratados Físicamente pero
dicen que les obligaron a cantar el
himno nacional ruso
tras estos casos de huérfanos ucranianos
deportados y adoptados por familia rusas
que asegura que quieren borrar la
identidad ucraniana